Couple other little things
about point clouds.
One is, wi, the point clouds, of course,
are sampled from the surface
that this depth sensor hits.
So you're, what you're getting is,
you're getting a sampling
of the surfaces,
which means there are no volumes.
You have to infer a volume, right?
So even if there's a nice
sphere right here,
you're going to get points along its
surface, and maybe if you move around,
you'll get more points from the surface,
but it's up to fut,
further processing to decide,
oh, that's the spherical volume.
So there's no explicit
representation of volumes.
There is an interesting element to it,
and that has to do with surface normals.
So, I assume you all know what a surface
normal is, you've got Geometry.
So the idea is you've got
some underlying surface, and
at any given point,
you can fit the tangent plane, and
the normal to that plane, that's
referred to as the surface normal.
You can think of it as a first order
local approximation to the surface.
Point clouds actually
have surface normals.
And you might ask how is that possible.
>> How is that possible?
>> Well, because it actually,
the sensor, it does a variety of little
processing to try to find little local
points nearby and fit that tangent plane
in order to estimate the surface normal,
and sometimes you, that's useful.
I will tell you that the surface
normal representation
is less robust than the actual
location of the point itself.
So, this cute little needle diagram,
in order to fit them, you have
to essentially take a little Gaussian
around the, the points that are there,
fit a little tangent plane to
those Gaussian weighted points,
and then that gives you,
an estimate of service normal.
You know, you have to figure out how
big a Gaussian do you want to use,
is a little bit like how big
a Gaussian do we use when we take
an image gradient, remember that?
We used to have to smooth out
the image to get rid of the noise, but
the more you smooth it,
the more you've spread out the gradient?
Same thing is true here.
The more, the more points you consider,
the more smoothly the surface
normal will vary.